when I was a kid really all we had to do  was to go to the movies we didn't have  money to have a television set so we  saved up our money all week and went to  the Saturday matinees it was like we we  would go around we lived in trailer  parks and we would go around to each of  the trailers and get soda bottles and  and we could go to the liquor store and  get money for the soda bottles so that  we could go and pay 50 Cent's later on  it was a dollar to go to the Saturday  matinees and that was the joy of our  childhood really when I went when we  went to the theaters it would be ours we  would spend there we would go in at you  know 10 or 11 in the morning and we  would stay there until the afternoon  because it would be a double feature and  then there would be like the serials  which were these ongoing episodes of you  know sometimes little funny things  sometimes news wheels but it was a an  all day Saturday experience going to the  movies